[Music]
hey
yeah
we're here we're doing it we're back we
might be drunk
ah good to have fully how the hell are
ya
he's got a new special out on youtube
what's the name of the special a joke
from the underground
i was there it was great great special
watch this special good to see you man
thanks for having me yeah it's great to
be here um yeah it's nice i'm gonna if
you want me to relapse on the show i can
really really would you do that uh i
don't
know
non-alcoholic beer
am i your first sober person no no of
course who else we had list on we had
burr right yeah never mind that's crazy
that i thought i would be your first
there's a lot of super cool so many
sober people now you're saying you had
lists before me how dare you yeah you
have bill burr before me
you know
um and beg to be on but uh yeah no i
won't relax but i'll drink uh yeah i'll
drink the non-alcohol it kind of gets me
drunk
really well it's like a psychological
thing um right because it's like the the
i don't know it just makes me feel drunk
um
yeah i guess i'm susceptible to
hypnotism well i mean they say like 68
of pills are placebo really and they
just people buy it the mind is such a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah and my mind is especially
country you know like if i if i think
you know during the coven [ __ ] when like
if i thought i had covet i'd have all
these symptoms and then the minute the
rapid test came back negative they'd all
go away that's so true isn't that crazy
that happened to me too i mean do you
will you have these ever will you drink
these yeah i do but i i i really need to
stop because i'm just getting fat and
not getting drunk it's like you get all
the bad parts yeah it's like decaf
coffee of alcohol you know you just get
the shits but you don't have the energy
yeah it's the same like no one's ever
like i need a cup of decaf no no it's
the same with do you have dude do you
ever [ __ ] women you're not attracted to
on the non-alcoholic beer
i mean i've
i mean i've done it sober so i've just
so i guess i've done it on the
non-alcoholic i'm gonna have a curl i'm
gonna have a regular beer but i do want
to try the nine hours yeah i've never
tried it it's good [ __ ] man it's like
beer but it doesn't give you the thing
that you want from beer
[Music]
um i always looked at non-alcoholic beer
like uh like a blow-up doll
yeah oh yeah well i'm like
why not nothing right you know right you
mean it's better to just not to just not
just just have like a soda or something
no for sure um
yeah i i mean the only reason i drink it
is because it actually does get me drunk
sometimes ooh that tastes pretty damn
good though well maybe i'm about to take
this back then yeah well yeah i heard
somebody compare having sex with a
condom is like having non-alcoholic beer
and i'm like that's not true because the
condom steps he's still [ __ ] yeah
still sex yeah there's still a person
there yeah it's definitely true because
i'll have this and i still won't have
sex with a condom so i feel like i
definitely have a difference
good point
well that's speaking of mental i mean
how many times you've seen ingrown hair
on your dick and you just go down this
spiral of like what have i done who am i
i gotta make some changes i hate myself
i gotta call my mom every day it's it's
it's just i if you go through like i
went through like a day once recently i
was like i had like i think 14 different
fears that day just like different oh
yeah and it's just like is it with
everything now just like covered monkey
pops i'm always terrified of bed bugs
oh i had those i think it feels like god
doesn't want anyone to interact with
each other yes like stay away from
everyone because everyone's just gonna
give you covet and herpes and bed bugs
god talks to his messengers on zoom yeah
yeah just all do it on zoom yeah because
it is like it's just so much yeah so
much [ __ ] stress this doesn't taste
bad it tastes good
you know what it's missing that the kick
it's like there is it's missing the
purpose of beer yeah it's missing like
well you know when you you have that one
little like there's like that little i
don't know it's alcohol it's missing out
you're like
you're like it's missing the thing that
i like alcohol you know
i think it's lacking is the point of it
i feel like i'm still here that's the
problem right yeah you know what it is
it's like a body without a soul
there you go that's what it is that's a
good ad it's a body without a soul
who needs a soul [ __ ] we've got too much
soul yeah but you know so uh but i i
don't know i get susceptible i'm you
know it's i guess it's part of my
hypochondria i get susceptible so when i
drink this i feel a little uh woozy you
know yeah well didn't tom cruise just
have a big uh flip out about or no he
had a flip out about antidepressants
years ago yeah and it resurfaced and
turns out he was kind of right or
something they're saying he was i don't
know you always say they i'm like
the internet is they
they keep saying like he was on it like
doctors have gone back and be like he
was onto something here
well i mean definitely not from where
he's coming from because he's like xenu
told me not to do it sure
like that's not like the scientists
aren't like yeah xenu and uh ronald
albert they are correct you know but i
mean i think it depends i mean i bought
antidepressants it helps really yeah oh
yeah oh yeah i can't oh i know i [ __ ]
up right i'm pretty depressed on it yeah
yeah
wet blanket over there not working
yeah well i gotta tell i grew up with a
scary dad like pull up in the driveway
dad's home you know battle stations go
hide and he got on any depressants and
he's like how are you he's like henry
winkler now
it's weird and i'm still like flinching
around him but it's wild and obviously i
don't think it works for everyone i do
think it's over diagnosed i will say
this everyone who's ever committed
suicide
should have been on anti-depressants you
don't think this absolutely hitler
except for hillary
we could have saved hitler it's a real
tragedy
hitler epstein if they're only medicated
we could have done they both did they
both did yeah but uh
but uh
you know
i just read biographies on hitler now
that's all i do i'm like obsessed with
hitler i've always said you need more
holocaust jokes you don't have enough
but there's six million of them
someone recently was like uh i found who
someone some kind
[Laughter]
we would not have been into hitler if he
was showing signs he was into us first
yeah
of course of course wasn't he a happy or
something no
you always hear that they always say he
was a half jew his mother's jewish no no
no i'm true i've read 12 biographies
this month come on i'm on the internet
they
this whole they think
that was a theory but it's not true i'm
just trying to be nice to trans people
they them it wouldn't suck if he was
jewish he'd be like i guess he's a
victim of the holocaust
but i did read uh this is sounds like a
joke but it's true his father his um
his father uh changed his last name to
hitler ah and so he had a different it
was originally goldstein yeah no it was
it was
i'm not getting this right but it was
something that
would have hard to get a hail going
because hale hitler sounds good it's
great in the biography they're literally
like he probably would have become
hitler because it's hard to get like a
hail shickle grouper going
it was literally like pickle grouper
absolutely yeah it was shickle you could
look at that [ __ ] i believe you're
chickel gruber so he didn't just open
like a bratwurst restaurant yeah exactly
i mean he might have been like kind of a
a nazi there like a soup notch just to
that level right a broth towards nazis
but like the service here is really bad
but yeah shickelgruber like hale hitler
is so catchy it is because he just like
that call me maybe song yeah exactly
because he changed because the father
changed his name to hitler six million
[ __ ] fans
if no one's like
do you hear about this new shickle
grouper guy like
you're
right true hail shrika group
you would have got you would have got to
know it name helps yeah game does help
maybe like can we call you shickle or
gruber anything about how many jews
change their name in show business john
stewart's john
why do you think i'm struggling so much
i don't [ __ ] change my name
your agent's like we can't get you
booked in the midwest this is not
hershey's
[ __ ] spell by name it's insane yeah
well you got a lot of a's in there in
the first the first name it's insane i
should have changed it but i'm from a
different time you can't change
now you have to change names to be more
ethnic so i came from the wrong time you
know i mean i'd have to
change it to like ronan
hershberg bagel locks and cream cheese i
don't know you have one of my favorite
jokes the one about your grandparents uh
going to uh are you like a jew from
kentucky oh yeah yeah does that go again
it's like uh
i live in new york now people were like
how did a jew end up in kentucky because
i'm from kentucky
and i'm like well when my grandpa left
europe before the holocaust he wasn't
very picky he wasn't like i don't know
how schwitz's louisville let me think
about it
that's a great bit well it was
it is like
this i don't know this is not the pet
peeve section but oh lay it off
there's no there's no order jews in new
york said jews only live in new york in
israel like they don't realize we're
like a scattered tribe oh yeah there's
jews in tucson they're choosing two saw
their jews everywhere it's like they
they really are they're just cockroaches
they go no but
and just think how many would it be
without the holocaust
that's right kind of needed it just to
keep that
overwhelming uh-huh someone else said
that someone said god who wants that
maybe with joe someone was like you know
there was less jews
uh there's there's more jews in germany
before the holocaust than there are now
or something like that
and i'm like yeah the holocaust was a
real setback yeah
you didn't know that huh yeah it is
interesting hitler like it's like trump
where the ratings just go up if he's on
it you know yeah like uh there's a
hitler the history channel is called the
hitler channel cnn plummeted after trump
exactly yeah hitler i will say hitler's
fa i'm like i'm basically a historian
now i just i the minute i turned 38 i
just started reading hitler biology
right right male and i've read like
like seven i'm watching movies now where
i'm like that's not historically
accurate
you're neil degrasse tyson with gravity
man
but with all just like schindler's list
that's what that's like
that's who you like to see movies with
the guy sits down and goes
actually right
well you know i but uh but yeah i know
you mean it is just uh i've gone in deep
you know um oh yeah and it's you know
not good because i know it's good
qualities now you know oh you know i'm
just like the painting or what's the
good stuff well he was a shitty painter
but he loved dogs you know
again smoking smoking's not great really
hated jews yeah yeah good point good
point i'll give you that one but uh but
yeah i don't know
evil is interesting it is it's you know
yeah it's just [ __ ] interesting you
know yeah yeah i mean
trump just got raided you know
that's fun that's what they said
yeah i that would be that that's gonna
be an interesting thing did they find
anything well they can't say melania was
flushing all the coke down the toilet
i don't think they're not going to be
able to release the information i think
you know oh really
we shouldn't talk okay we're just coming
out in like a oh
good point good point yeah we should
just talk about trump being in jail
are you going to be the leader on the
very bottom martial argo
all right i'll see you all in hell
but um
but yeah uh oh that was gonna i saw
giant the biggest fight ever i was
telling sam on the uh i did a show
takoma comedy club a giant fight in the
audience oh yeah like a melee out in the
crowd i mean huge worst i've ever i've
never seen any i one time i did a show i
was opening for madigan at the
town hall here and the lights just came
on in the middle some old lady like
smacked someone else and they escorted
her out but i didn't really see it and
it wasn't that big a deal this time i'm
on the show
and they apparently asked this guy to
leave and he uh
he the security asked him nicely three
times the third time the guy and i gotta
get this right because i kept on saying
chokehold and joe list was like don't
say choco that's like an mma term that's
not nearly as bad he strangled him he
started choking
actually choking him and the security
guard like passed out for a second five
people jumped on him punched him the
lights went on i'm just how big was the
security guard that he did it too what
how big he was he was small yeah yeah he
was small there's an epidemic of tiny
comedy from security that's true yeah
like well i'm looking i'm like that
dude's not going to help he was small
it's a failed comment i'm pretty sure
it's in elementary school i was at
caroline's once and uh there was a guy
on stage in the front row and he just
wouldn't let me get a joke out and he
was a scary looking dude and i kind of
it was like 15 minutes of this and i
kind of turned him like are you gonna
toss him or not oh yeah the guy walks
over and he whispers and the guy uh he
he just was like this and walked away i
was like what'd he go he's he said no
that's usually not what toss me yeah at
the same time like yeah i don't blame
you i'm scared wow
what if the cops did that oj we're
taking you in i'm good
well that's why i didn't go the first
time um but yeah i mean no it's well
good for him for trying he did a great
job and he and he i talked to him after
a security guard he was unfaithful i was
like in a trauma blanket on the street
but he was like
he was like unfaithful they did a great
job of kicking the guy out but the
lights turned on and i'm just standing
there yeah this is like 30 minutes into
my set uh
and the guy in the crowd choking him is
a tough looking dude yeah really tough
looking
the
population people i think are tough
looking it's pretty wide but yeah he was
really tough looking how old are we
talking he's probably like 30s but this
was like
manchester by the sea like abrupt
violence like i'm like how did that guy
function in society the guy quietly
asked him to leave a third time and he
just started strangling him like how is
he well tacoma is like a blue-collar
kind of rust belty tough town you know
yeah
yeah yeah
well the worst part is
i was doing abortion material and it was
kind of tense yeah and then i kicked it
out and the lights went back down and i
just went back to tense materials so
there's no there was no relief yeah
you're like i should have aborted that
guy i didn't say that okay good yeah all
right you gotta say that i was like
thank you for proving my point but
here's the saddest part about all that
it's a horrible thing a guy got
strangled and [ __ ] your setup you're in
a trauma blanket but at the end you're
like did you get the clip
i didn't get the clip
i didn't give a clip i did it
that happened to me at one of their
clubs once i had like the greatest crowd
working moment i had ever had yes and i
was like did the camera roll they're
like it was that a bad
have you all seen nope it's like the
camera just breaks whenever there's
anything yeah yeah well you'll get it
what do you think i heard mixed it's
interesting okay um
but i uh
yeah it was i didn't film and i don't
know if it would have captured him but
it would have captured my like because
in those situations
comics people love comics in that
situation because it's not that hard to
come back yes yes as long as you don't
[ __ ] yourself in the fetal position
they're like you're a [ __ ] genius
exactly meanwhile you say brilliant
material
yeah
that's it yeah that's really all you
have to do is not [ __ ] the bed yeah yeah
exactly it's the same thing if you
prefer like all black crowd if you just
don't if you're like the one white guy
and you just don't [ __ ] your pants or
like i like this guy you know what i
mean
but um i uh i want to see the one white
guy go up there it's all black he's like
i [ __ ] myself
if you just act like a white guy you'll
kill you know you're like oh man it's
scary on the way up here they're like
i always thought that'd be so funny for
a late night a comic to just come out
and she's like oh i just shot myself
but uh i was really in a bad mood too
because the club is great but [ __ ] uh
i don't know can i i'll tell you carlos
meant to see i was headlining earlier
carlos marcia was headlining later that
night and he wouldn't let me use the
green room damn this is recently this
was the show oh my god so i get there
they're like you can't use the green
room carless mancia's merch is in there
so like my [ __ ]
what though i couldn't be in the green
room because of a [ __ ] hacked [ __ ]
merch wow
you got outshined by merch not only that
i hear he's doing a bunch of holocaust
material on the road right now i wanted
to leave my joke notebook in there to
have him talk about a loud jewish mother
is he back he's a mexican right
yeah half half about half carlos
my mother was always like carlos i think
it's ned hell hellness the worst part
about grown up mexican is your loud
jewish mother
[Laughter]
so i couldn't go in the green room so
when the fight happened i got nowhere to
go [ __ ] it up yeah
yeah the [ __ ] his merch is [ __ ]
protected whatever that is what shirt
with a joke he stole from george lopez
or whatever
damn
was he does he still sell a lot of
tickets there oh yeah of course yeah
that's why that's why that happened yeah
well we got to let you go we got uh sam
shirts are coming out
we got we got marcia right after that
next episode is just you all and carlos
macias koozie you're just talking to
that
this guy keeps trying to come into my
green room
that's where my shirts are
at least the club i mean i know the kid
went down and got strangled which sucks
but at least he had your back club was
great yeah yeah i did a that's a good
question we're naming names i did
bananas and
not poughkeepsie
hasbro heights
highway right off the highway oh yes
route 9 in jersey in a hundred just
sounds so tough oh my god route 9. the
only good thing is you get those like
classic jersey diners right around yes
that's the only thing that area has gone
for so true so i'm doing bananas and i'm
getting
heckled mercilessly by like a giant
table of of uh like electricians it was
some union and i'm just dying out there
and i'm like is anyone gonna do anything
like this is [ __ ] crazy and the lady
goes there's 80 of them
that was her answer and i was like okay
and that was it and i had to go back
into material
that's why you don't sell to a group
that the good clubs don't sell to groups
that big no
it becomes a private event it's a
corporate event they control the show
yeah they had me by the balls and i just
it was dance monkey dance and i just had
to count the minutes i once kicked
it was like an office party i once
kicked
30 people out of the show once wow and i
was a feature it was a very it was a
very it was a shitty move on my phone
hey let's hear it how the hell did that
happen it was like an office party they
sat up front i didn't realize their
office party and they didn't all just
get kicked out at once like
demanded i think i saw gary goldman like
the man someone get kicked out on a
video or something like i like that i'm
gonna do that i forgot he'd been like
headlining for like 50 years i'm like
yeah i'm like featuring at the looty bit
it's like my third time
which one
this was uh
god [ __ ] which one was it it was tulsa
okay or oklahoma or auschwitz one of the
three
and i was performing and it was just
they were just heckling right away
and um
and i actually learned an important
lesson because i had there was a cruise
ship comic after me
and you know he
they don't always have the best material
and always but he had some really good
insights and i learned a big lesson
because they were heckling so much that
the minute i got on stage i just started
yelling at them which is always bad yeah
could just not even let the audience see
you
like my first impression their first
impression of me of me was like [ __ ] you
you piece of [ __ ] and then i'd also try
to go into a joke and they'd be heckling
and i wouldn't get to the end of the
joke and the cruise ship guy afterwards
saying
let yourself get to the end of the joke
get to the punch line and then do it but
don't let them see you like because you
can still get laughs even if you're
walking you can still get laughs i
learned a lot from that but i uh you
know just be quiet and to let the crowd
hear that yeah when you're like quiet as
possible exactly yeah i learned a lot
the cruise ship comic later killed
himself but i learned about joking but
i learned to i learned a lot but like i
kicked out like three people and they
kicked them out like oh these [ __ ]
are out of here you know i'm doing like
the bill hicks speech yeah yeah you [ __ ]
but they kicked out three but the rest
of the office party so they were still
heckling so they just kicked them out
throughout the world wow so like 30
people by the end of the show are you
addressing it like yeah get good yeah
get him too oh yeah [ __ ] his wife yeah
i'm yeah [ __ ] you yeah yeah
that's kind of fun after a minute like
after the 13th one you're like this is
like wacko it is fun i mean they're
yelling like we'll see you in the
parking lot
yeah yeah
see you in the parking lot jew dang
cook's shirts are in the green room
[Laughter]
but so uh but yeah i learned uh i
learned a lot from them but yeah it's uh
heckling you shouldn't have to like at a
certain point you don't want to have to
like be good at dealing with it it's
brutal and it's so frustrating too
because a lot of these crowds are like
you're like shut up they're like well
you're not funny i'm like you haven't
listened yeah the only way to get the
joke is to you gotta listen to the setup
and the punch but they listen to the
setup for four seconds and they go i'm
not laughing [ __ ] this guy i was at the
airport not funny
nothing funny about you being at the
airport if you listen i was gonna get to
a 911 twist
but you pulled out i live with a yellow
i was doing something about dating app
because i'm a hack and i said something
about bumble i was like talking about
bubble and i clearly had like a joke and
i don't think dude didn't get materials
hack i was just joking but i was doing a
joke and uh and someone yelled out you
should put a video of yourself on bumble
that's how you do it i'm like you think
i'm just up here trying to get a dating
advice yeah like you really think i
don't have a joke about this i'm just
like how was the show it was great i got
some really good dating advice that's
the main point oh the worst the worst is
when they're just talking at the table
and you have to be like what's going on
i had it the other night the seller
there's a there's a table and i'm just
like
they're talking so loudly i'm like how's
it going you know one of those and there
and and she was just like oh we were
just talking which i'm like yeah that
phrase should never be uttered we were
just talking we're just talking about a
friend that's just like what you just
said
oh that's an excuse the post joke uh
reflection of course thank you yeah so
you know i have to deal with them and
they're just and i'm
you're mad at yourself for not kind of
slamming them but at the same time like
how do i do what i'm trying to do is
just get this back in the materials
angry you can't look definitely on the
road sometimes in new york you'll be
like [ __ ] you yeah back in the day you
could back in the day you could be oh
yeah [ __ ] you your [ __ ] now you'll get
like a restraining order
now you have to be like [ __ ] you you uh
respectable citizen whatever
saw yeah clip of bill hicks where he's
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
that's not how you're supposed to do it
he's a great comic you're not that's not
the move he's a great comic he might not
have been consistent
like i don't know but he also was
playing shitholes that's the thing is
like when you have those ideas and
you're playing like dumps in this [ __ ]
of course you know he's not playing the
a rooms and yeah he's in the store which
is amazing how well he could do doing
like yeah he was a master yeah i mean he
really i mean like i i've talked to
comics you say like yeah he would go to
the places that disagreed with him as
opposed to the people now who are like
i only play san francisco in portland
that's like the modern bill hicks is
like
i only do burlington vermont yeah yeah
20 minutes of chairs
and they do like they're like i do jokes
about making fun of racism like that
would be controversial if you're in like
oklahoma but if you're in like seattle
it's just pandering sometimes the third
joke is pandering you really gotta go to
the sticks of oklahoma oklahoma
you really you know it's uh
yeah he really was an incredible cop one
of the best but some of those
clips
you gotta you gotta be
as you said you can't look angry when
you look angry they won't look angry
yeah
and this is much truer i think on the
road where the view of comics
because there are times where you're
having a great time and then if you snap
all the arts even the ones who liked you
are like whoa because the truth is even
if you're doing well and this is part of
it most people in audience especially on
the road think of you as a birthday
clown and the minute you get mad they
see it as like a birthday clown yelling
at a little kid what kind of [ __ ]
balloon do you want you give it you know
they start getting mac and they think
that they're you're there just to
entertain them yes and so you are they
and you are
i mean there it's that you know sure
there is some dignity into it artistic
versus entertaining it's like that
beautiful right yang but like when you
snap they're like
oh like why the birthday clown's getting
mad right now you know you have to like
you can't show real emotion on stage but
you snap a lot more early on when you're
playing those when you're just
consistently in bedrooms when yeah
i don't really snap anymore because i
don't either i'm like i'm pretty spoiled
with
the rooms i get to play now and
but starting out i was like man my fuse
was like [ __ ] oh shame and we all
snap i think pete holmes said this once
i was like it really stuck with me he's
like you can always tell an amateur
comic because they snap too soon and i
was like that was just me a hundred
percent yeah i would whisper i'd be like
shut up you [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] yeah
that's the same way it's just like you
just that you just we were just crazy
back then right now just like it was
just a different time and you're young
and you're bombing more and you're
trying to you're not making it you're
poor so you're kind of like you're
letting a little out on them too like
yes you know how many shows i've done
tonight [ __ ] you this [ __ ] works you
know all the anger of all the struggle
just comes out in that one thing but
exactly but it is you can't you gotta
like and i i think now like when people
heckle i'm pretty like fun about it and
just do it in a way where i'm like
because you gotta do it in a way where
you can kind of like make them look bad
while while not looking upset you know
best thing i ever did because you know
you ever go to a club and they go what
do you want us to say if uh somebody
heckles like you know if somebody
heckles do you have a thing like a
phrase like get him a water that means
throw him out whatever that [ __ ] is
get him a water and i always say if
someone heckles don't do anything
chitchat get on that yeah get on the
chick cause chit chat to me is way worse
than heck the heck i can handle i can
make a joke out of it i'm just like it's
like a gnat in my ear and you're
throwing me off and you start flubbing
words like i just
what's going on over here and it just
ruins the show way more than a heckler i
actually mean when i say heckle like i
mean chit chat is the worst because it's
indifferent yes it's indifferent it's
just heckle is actually fine getting
someone yelling outside right i can use
that you can use that you can riff
that's fine but it's it's
like it's doable chatting is just a it's
indifferent
and then if it's a big room only you can
[ __ ] hear it yeah you look like
[ __ ] uh you look like donnie darko
talking to like an imaginary person up
there yeah yeah heckler is almost like
like like a [ __ ] being like i'm guard
yeah let's go let's go yeah but but you
know uh the chatter it's like a dude
just who keeps like flicking your ears
yeah
exactly i was on stage
that same show the [ __ ] guy was doing
a toast loudly in front of me
give it up for charles he was a good guy
he was in the navy 20 years and the
other guy's doing a thing it's like a
one-act leader yeah and i'm like
i'm like you know i didn't
i'm like
what are you all gonna go what are you
all toasted about and they all look at
me like my job
[Laughter]
and i have such low self-esteem i'm like
am i i'm sorry i didn't mean to be yeah
but it's like
i don't go on stage with a microphone
because i'm like want to be ignored i
clearly want to touch it so when
someone's giving a toast in the front
row it's a perversion of the craft we're
doing yes and then we look especially
like [ __ ] because like look at me
with a microphone still being ignored we
look like either even bigger asshole's
calling this a craft yeah
yeah that's true
did you have a code word for kicking
people out no but i heard i think what
mark was saying about the wall mine was
get that [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here yeah
i really that's what i usually just say
like if it gets that bad i don't mind
looking back i mean you if i want to i
never get kicked people out almost ever
so if it gets to that point then
usually they do it before i do they're
all they're like all your fans too so
it's a complicated you know what the
smoothest is i was i think it was at the
houston improv and i did a bunch of
jokes and you know you heard like
something might have been weird for two
seconds like whatever and then a couple
hours later you're having a beer in the
green room they're like oh we kicked
like 12 people out you're like what like
yeah yeah we just kept it quiet too man
you guys are good yeah like ninjas
happened to me at houston improv too is
it people in the front i didn't even ask
to kick them out i was yeah i was trying
to save them
they were so drunk and they were like do
a shot of me i'm like i'm good do i do a
show i'm like
[ __ ] it what the hell i'll do a shot
yeah so i do a shot trying to like save
them yes i'm getting drunk during the
show trying to save this table they're
like he's your biggest fan can he just
have a picture with you i'm like during
the show all right [ __ ] it i bring the
mic over i'm like this is me trying to
save this table i with the mic i'm like
did you get your [ __ ] picture i'm
[ __ ] with them it's like i'm trying
to save this
they just keep going to the point that
the
you know the the staff kicked him out
and i was like i tried yeah i tried to
help you more than your part on that one
and uh yeah but houston it's they're
they're they're drivers
big room too
the other thing at the end of the day
it's just alcoholism it's not it's not
it's not you're literally just fighting
alcoholism there was a comic i think it
was at hilarities and i forgot who it
was i it'll hit me at some point but he
had his code word was to kick someone
out was get this person a cola a cola
and he was like i apparently kept saying
hey get this guy a cola because the guy
was bad no one does anything and he just
[Laughter]
i love those old story this guy jessie
pop great comic he started writing
yeah funny guy hilarious but he uh he
was at some show in michigan and the
headliner was like this classic hack you
know bag like literally a briefcase full
of props and jokes and tricks and jesse
pop is featuring he gets off the host
goes back on to stall because the
headliner isn't there yet he runs in
with his bag of tricks he's got a trench
coat with a rubber chicken in it the
whole thing and rainbow suspenders and
he goes huh i'm here i'm here i'm ready
okay uh what's the mall in this town
what's the mall and jesse goes uh uh the
star line mall and he goes all right
starlight mall i got i guess he's he's
got an opener about the the mall the
local mall so
he's sweating he goes out there and he
goes hey everybody i was at the starline
mall today and jesse goes oh [ __ ] that
burned down five years ago
so the crowd's like boom my uncle died
in that fire he went from prop comic to
edgelord in a second
yeah and though the whole room just
turned on him and he did like an hour
after that to silence he's just anthony
jefferson now and suspenders yeah
people being pulled out in blankets and
uh women crying and there's like a
candlelight vigil that's so good dude
it was pretty high yeah jessie pop was
so funny i mean i remember he had a bit
this is like right the the huck finn
controversy remember the whole you know
n word gym sure yeah yeah everyone he
was the first guy heard do a bit like
this
he was like you know do do they censor
and we're do you know do you censor art
do you censor old books right and he
goes you know and where jimmy goes i got
a crazy idea how about just calling him
jim
[Laughter]
like that was right in front of all of
us yeah he was great he had a million of
those where you're like oh that's so
good
um
yeah the worst i guess the worst echo
but it was my fault did i ever tell you
this the story i was i was at a
for the first four years i was just
performing at pizza restaurants but in
the back of pizza right sure in indiana
i don't know why that was just the
market yeah
and i'll have this show and you know how
when you're younger you want to be edgy
but you're also like
don't be confident so you're like a
little kid with a gun yeah i gotta use
this i'm gonna say the c word how to use
this you know which by the way very
relatable in indiana yeah
and i was doing a joke about um sids you
know
dead big which is like that's a hard
joke for me to figure out now sudden
infant death sudden infant death that's
like the hardest like i could i wouldn't
do a joke about that now right and this
was like i was like four months in it's
like time to take on sids
you know i've gone through the ropes now
it's really i really gotta chat like i'm
like four months it's time to challenge
myself
see if i can get the audience back on my
side it's like how about i try to get
them on my side in the first floor yeah
yeah so i go up and i do i was probably
a couple years in but i was due it was a
couple weeks ago but i was doing uh
i was doing a sid joke and this one guy
was grilling me in the audience
and like really grilling me and even
that was such an [ __ ] oh boy i'm not
even like i'm just like what the [ __ ]
your problem yeah
meanwhile papa john's in the back going
he didn't say the n word
no that's uh too dude i did that early
[ __ ] we're like well you're just trying
to provoke a crowd right cause you're
just trying to get you're not funny but
you yeah i'd rather be memorable right
but so like so what's what do you have
what you don't like to joke and he goes
we had a kid who
died and
i just go straight into like my cleanest
material i'm just like uh man yeah you
ever been to the airport in gas prices
and i'm so fat and oh i overdrafted
yesterday just doing like my cleanest
and uh
and after like 30 minutes i guess i kind
of get them back a little you know
and then afterwards i go up to the guys
and his wife and i'm like i'm really
sorry and he goes i was just joking
[Laughter]
[Music]
where you do just like all like sponges
are weird then you get to your closure
so uh sit
what do you guys think babies
but that taught me a lesson too it's
like don't do a joke if if people get
offended you're gonna crumble right if
you're gonna you can do a joke about
whatever you want
but don't [ __ ] but be prepared to
stand behind it if you can't stand
behind it because like deep down i'm not
like deep down i i want people like me
and i'm not like yes same there's some
things where i'm like you know
i'll do a joke i think it's good but
like overall i don't want people to hate
me so like if i do i'll i'll crumble so
it's like i just can't do those jokes we
always talk about that group that's like
the comics like i walked half the room
i'm the real deal and you're like that
sucks
yeah i remember there was a comic who
did that when i was young
and this article was like but the real
people stayed and i'm like no the real
people left yeah
you got to perform for everybody they're
all real people right exactly and that's
like civilized for them look those are
the good people like to not like a joke
to not like a comic and then just leave
is kind of the civilized thing to do
yeah that's true yelling [ __ ] out and
i'm sure the club loves that too like oh
thanks [ __ ] no it's it's tough
because you learn when you you're
younger you learn you want to be and
they're these are great comics like doug
stanton and bill hicks are great comics
but part of being a comic is
learning not to be too influenced by
them because they're yeah they're their
own thing
and like but here's the problem is like
you want to
like you could have a great sid's joke
yeah it's possible like what's that guy
junior stopka you know him yeah he's got
that brilliant joke i hope i'm not
giving it away but he says uh you know
the holocaust actually had a lot of
[ __ ] people in it but there's no
photos because they're all smiling yeah
that's a great and you're like damn
that's [ __ ] brilliant but obviously
dark as hell
but what about when he had to figure
that joke out yeah you know and that's
the hard part about these edgy jokes is
like there's brilliant amazing smart a
jokes that people love well yeah but
they had to play with it
stan hope is also like he would have
been a great clean comic yeah true i
mean so it's like he happens to be this
type of comic young comics learn the
worst the they make the [ __ ] look easy
and then yes not and then young comics
think it's easy you should be able to
write clean
when you're starting not even if you're
not a clean comic user i mean dave
vettel will write a great clean joke
killer classic i just think and
i guess i learned this from louis i mean
it's true for all the great companies
you've got to have variety in your ass
you've got to if you have variety you
should have clean material just from the
sense of having variety you know what i
mean it's you know i you just shouldn't
have [ __ ] that dude i'm doing an hour of
fisting jokes
crazy but louie also said something that
i also like really stuck with me is that
like logic
if you can stand behind the logic of the
joke i love that if you can
agree with that stand by the logic even
if it feels offensive if in your head
you're like logically yep i'm making a
solid point if you can do that
then even if people get offended you can
still stand behind that and it can help
the way the audience perceives you
because you're like look i'm just making
a point what's a good example of it well
my sis baby joke lacked
i think i was like [ __ ] the dead baby
in the joke and i'm like there's no luck
what's the example i got a bunch of
these these logic jokes well like uh
you know the guy goes i don't see color
and i go i'm black and he's like no
you're not i'm like aha so it's a cute
joke but it's
you said it so i'm going off your
your sentence and you're using the logic
like you're you're not trying to in
another sense you're not trying to
offend people no no i think most like
i'm trying to think what other like but
we go off gut reaction so much a lot of
it
a lot of those jokes are
i saw something that i disagree with let
me break down why this is right yes
that's a logic joke it's kind of a
social norm that we all accepted but it
is flawed and here's why right right
well i guess i mean not to keep on
accordingly but i got the logic joke for
him that is offensive is that joke he
does where he's like uh
uh
during the cove there was every every it
was like three seven people died and
they're like every day it's another 9 11
and he's like when do we start gauging
death by 9 11 yeah like the holocaust
was like 400 911 yeah he's like the not
9 11 wasn't that bad it's just one
and it's like that's something that's
offensive but you're like if you get
called to task you're like there's logic
there i'm not there i'm not trying to
effect you know yeah i love it i love
jokes that's one great thing about
comedies you get to kind of tell that
truth and not
be an [ __ ] i mean you're probably
considered an [ __ ] but i'm like
it's just what is right you know it's a
good thing to it's not just simply like
what's it's a good thing for you
personally to think about if people get
offended like if you're on stage people
get offended like in your head just be
like no no i'm following the logic here
right you know and that's a good way to
react sorry it's just you know yeah my
old joke uh
women would always be like when caitlyn
jenner was new and fun and everybody's
like loved her oh i love katelyn she's
she's so beautiful and i go well you
look like her and they'd go [ __ ] you
but when i was thinking my dad's
acceptance by the way that we don't like
her for who she is right yeah of course
yeah good point good
yeah i always say ellen was was pushed
back on she was gay and now she's a [ __ ]
that is that is equality
[Music]
exactly i'm not saying she's a cup but
i'm saying
no i mean you should see people as like
yeah you should be annoyed you should be
able to be annoyed by content of their
character the problem is is that like
most people in any group are just awful
because most people are awful so it's
just like it's just like anytime you
talk [ __ ] about someone like you're
racist like no no just most people in
every group are shitty yeah yeah and
you're shitty too you just haven't
gotten caught exactly yeah especially
people in power they're just
gonna be an [ __ ] did i cut you off
there come on i was gonna say didn't
someone uh object to one of your jokes
this weekend and speak to you i like the
formality object
[Laughter]
like after every joke you're like if
anyone has any objections to this
material
stand up or uh
objection your honor there's no logic
behind this joke
so i've been bringing this up a lot
because it's a fascinating debate and
i'd like to hear what you guys sure your
input will deliberate real quickly yeah
yeah yeah um recess no so uh
i have a joke with [ __ ] in it and a
woman was just
not laughing the whole show and i kept
you know when you're doing well but one
woman in kentucky yeah one was like just
and i'm like oh you almost smiled hey
almost got a smirk out here and that's
killing just calling her out and then i
keep [ __ ] with her and i'm like is
she laughing and they're like she's not
laughing you know they're loving it and
we had a good time and then i'm selling
merch after like a [ __ ] sellout and
she comes up and i'm like oh she's
probably gonna chitchat and want to buy
a shirt and make amends and she goes
would you say the n word on stage and
she said the word she said it yeah yeah
it's kentucky
the first one and not the second one
that's a good isn't that funny yeah so
we're already off to a bang i'm like oh
geez okay but i didn't think twice about
i'm like no i probably wouldn't and she
goes so why do you say [ __ ] and i go
well it's a joke and it gets laughs and
whatever it only works with that word
and she goes well i have a down syndrome
kid or whatever and i was like well i'm
sorry
but uh what'd you think about the
holocaust joke she goes those are fine
and i go so it's only when it affects
you and she's like well it affects me
greatly and i'm like i get that and i'm
sorry but
if everyone in line had a son with
cancer a suicide mom whatever like we
could do this all day and then now
there's no act yeah and also i mean like
the n-word was never the scientific
nomenclature for black people the n-word
was never
it was never like in that that was
always kind of sl that was always kind
of like pejorative slang yes yeah and we
didn't enslave
[ __ ] people as well it's just no one
first of all whether you think the r
word is offensive or not no one thinks
it's equal to the n word like that like
he does we need some mentally challenged
uh rappers to take the word back yes and
call each other that it's always like
the parents of the kid because they
really just all they want is to be like
you have had a really hard life and i
get it and i said i've had that too
and i do i'm with you i i do sympathize
but uh
now we're just weighing things oh no i
don't think that you got it no you got
me completely wrong i don't simplify no
no
no i think they're [ __ ]
and they want to be like they want to
stand out for what they're doing right
and it's i actually don't i don't i i
sympathize if you have a mental handicap
children but if you're gonna like
openly get mad at someone for telling a
joke about that it's like you're kind of
just saying i really hate my life taking
care of him and i want this to be
appreciated it's like it's just like
knowledge you want to be acknowledged
and that's like you just love your
[ __ ] kid sitting in the front is
tough too because like if she was in the
back i don't think it would have it
wouldn't affected the show at all yeah
but when you're in the front and you're
looking for a reaction like she doesn't
have to laugh at that that's okay to not
laugh at that but then making it a thing
that's kind of what making it a thing is
where i yeah
obviously anyone can be offended by
anything you have a right to be yeah you
have a right to not find something funny
but when you're like making a thing
costing the person you're being a
fascist because on a sense
you're saying i want everyone subjected
to what i value as being untouchable
yeah but that same person who sets them
setting themselves up for hypocrisy
because that same person who says don't
make jokes about that is going to laugh
at something else yeah that someone else
thinks you shouldn't make jokes about
yes so the holocaust is worse than your
mentally challenged son yes yes
and not by a little like
that
by like by like a [ __ ] there were
mentally challenged people who died in
the holocaust i mean unless her kid was
jewish too like like like there's more
minorities in the one than the other but
like it's just like
yeah
but
i just think it's like
yeah if you if we did what everyone
wanted like you said there would be no
jokes yeah and uh and they just get bad
because like obviously mentally
challenged kids wouldn't get mad
mentally challenged people will get mad
by that joke no they would laugh
at everything yeah but they would laugh
uh but like it's just it's to me that's
more like that's more just wanting
acknowledgement in an arrogant way and
just here's the thing and what and like
why'd she line up for the shirt yeah you
wanted a moment she wanted to be like
here's where you went wrong
just because you have a men look having
a mentally challenged kid is hard and
it's a noble job but just because you
have one doesn't mean you're not already
an [ __ ] mm-hmm of course you know
anyone can have a mentally ill kid i'm
an [ __ ] i could have one there's no
like maybe that's why she had god smited
her yeah so it's like an issue if you
have a mental and a dead doesn't mean
you're not a prick just like if you get
offended by any joke and stand up and
get offended yeah i get it but you're a
prick just like most people are pricks
it also doesn't help that my merch is
helmets
give her one for free yeah i gave her
one i signed it
with the n-word on it
she was also late to the show and i said
hey you're tardy
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we're having fun with that those
are the ones who wear helmets i feel
like their heads are the ones we should
give them
we lost her as a member she was on the
patreon thanks a lot we're the ones who
should have helmets
is true yeah yeah yeah i held it on here
it's like a little too late
i'm sorry
my brother's mentally handicapped there
you go this one's my son no
people aspergers
who isn't these days every time he sees
like a man
hey yeah you can say it that's what you
should have said
ah
you're right you want a tit for tat
of a pro what do you call it affliction
i could say because i use asperger's to
get out of
conflicts there you go didn't kevin
spacey do that no he said he said i'm
gay yeah yeah gay but it was like it was
he was accused of underage yeah which
i'm like yeah that's not gay yeah
no no no one's ever been like you homo
when you catch
a guy with an underage that's not the
thing jeffrey is like look i'm gay
all right i know it's a problem i'm gay
and i have sex with men
i think it's more about the eating them
no no no no
what a weird bundy i'm pushy i'm pushing
a pushy guy fume
is the safe way to quit smoking fumes
100 canadian maple handcrafted inhaler
is made to replace the hand-to-mouth
habit simply insert their
non-addictive flavored cores
uh fume cores come and doze the flavors
like peppermint lemon berry bliss ooh
yeah the flavors are good they taste
nice i love the little pipe inhaler
thing it's so cool fun to suck on fun to
put in your mouth there's no smoke no
vape and no nicotine to worry about even
if you're not trying to quit smoking
fumes core can help with relaxation
energy and more whether you're a smoker
or an ex-smoker who still struggles with
cravings fume is the perfect tool for
you it's time to create positive habits
and quit naturally with fume and we're
here to make it easier head to fume dot
com slash drunk use promo code drunk to
save 10 off your whole order save money
by eliminating cigarettes and save on
your initial purchase of fume that's 10
off your entire order at b r e a t h e f
u m dot com slash drunk and use code
drunk
the summer months are here time to stay
fueled and hydrated making hydration a
priority helps us feel healthier in our
everyday lives one stick of liquid iv in
16 ounces of water hydrates you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone liquid iv products taste
great with 10 great flavors like concord
grape lemon lime tropical punch i love
the i love the punch that's my go-to oh
yeah it's terrific use liquid iv first
thing in the morning before a workout
when you feel run down after a long
night out which would what we're doing
here oh yeah got to manage that
hydration you know had a few too many
bodega cats yeah that right the single
serve packaging helps keep you hydrated
while on the go
i i definitely have used this uh and i
know you have too i'm a daily at this
point liquid iv contains five essential
vitamins b three five six twelve and
vitamin c it contains three time the
electro
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks made with premium ingredients
liquid iv is free from gluten dairy and
soy liquid iv uses cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com and use code drunk at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk
liquidity.com
hell yeah
summer is starting to wind down and i am
busier than ever that's why i'm saving
for saving time with factor factors
ready to eat meals delivered to your
house they make it easy to stay on top
of your schedule while still sticking to
your goals with factor a quick lunch or
a fully prepared dinner is just two
minutes away these heat and eat meals
are a lifesaver when you have no free
time factors new protein plus preference
makes it easy to power up with
deliciously satisfying meals and at
least 30 grams of protein per serving
factor offers 30 meals a week
change your order up every week choose 4
to 18 per week
pause or reschedule your deliveries any
time these chef crafted recipes are
packed with restaurant quality flavor
and everything is dietitian approved wow
stop spending your precious hours at the
store and in the kitchen let factor
deliver ready-made meals right to your
door each factor meal arrives prepared
pre-prepared by their team of chefs they
are ready to heat and eat in two minutes
they offer vegan veggie protein plus
keto and calorie smart options plus cold
pressed juices smoothies energy bites
extra protein veggie sides and more i
had these they're great i love those
smoothies
the killer go dot factor 75.com
slash
drunk130 use drunk130
to get
135 bucks off
six boxes
that's code drunk codedrunk130
at
code.factor75.com
all right i hope i got that right yeah
it's code.factor75.comdrunk130.
thank you yeah he said it like it was a
string and a parachute like i'm gay
i got i'm out that was a tough one yeah
he did gay it's also norman's
catchphrase
i'm gay oh yeah maybe it's just a norman
fan yeah it had nothing to do with the
apology he was just like it was terrible
i didn't do any of that yeah i'm gay
follow mark norrish
as yeah as he got arrested he actually
said comedy yeah ben lott was a huge fan
he kept saying praise all up
they got it from you that's a weird
twist you know some kid told me he saw a
kid in an open mic go i'm kevin hart i'm
like what the [ __ ] yeah like that's a
weird thing to steal because it's
i don't know it's still a joke no i
thought of it with that i'm like come on
please say someone else yeah you should
say i'm mark norman oh
yeah that's not bad um
[Music]
well yeah do you mean first off do you
have peeves
oh yeah yeah i got peeves uh mentally
handicapped kids
um
yeah what do i got peeps i uh i tried to
write some down today you got one i got
you by the whole time okay well yeah i
was we get to bill maher music playing
[Laughter]
new rules you kind of need that okay
i need the music to get like round man
he gets the easiest applause breaks in
comedy history he's like so i stepped in
gum
and he gets the maddest of his crowd
ever i know one joke he's murdering for
like 20 minutes one joke at the bomb
he's like oh okay liberal [ __ ] i'm
like they're your fans
that's actually a pep but we'll get to
it all right right right there what what
this thing where it's like
comics who think they're edgy i i don't
know but bill maher whatever i think his
show is good yeah
some of the jokes are not great but like
his show is good he makes some good
points but just outside of that i just
mean
comics who think they're edgy when
really the joke is just not that great
right yeah and then they think the
audience is just sensitive yeah they
just go through their whole life not
realizing they're just not that good of
a writer you don't get it yeah they're
just sensitive they're just like you
know like they're like i want to rape
every jew in the holocaust oh i guess
you're all sensitive
the other day oh okay san francisco yeah
they always do that they're like i think
hitler was really right about everything
oh i guess you're not world war two
bosses yeah
yes yeah yes
i think slavery made some good points
okay
okay
yeah so it's like triggered and that is
the triggered challenge when you have
jokes that are edgy yeah they're good
because you're like that didn't work is
it because right is it because they're
[ __ ] or is it because it's not that
good of a joke and i do think once
the joke is good it will work yeah i
mean
i i think you i think that thing the
edge lord like the edgy but not that
edgy and then blaming the audience for
sensitivity sure that's that's that's a
new rule
i hate the flip side of that too which
is uh hey uh where where are you from
the guy's like uh new jersey goes whoa
okay man jesus why are you yelling at me
it's like he's he's on the spot he's not
a comedian he said new jersey he said it
kind of erratically and now you're
you're mad at him yeah i hate that the
where he from's also a pet peeve well
yeah i just needed an example but yeah
yeah anything like that you guys uh you
guys married no we're just dating oh
okay
what are you waiting for yeah like okay
i gotta pee i gotta crazy yeah yeah
okay i'll do it let's build my
okay people
no i'm sitting on the train
it's hot as balls
the train's not air-conditioned already
a peeve yeah that's like a big p right
no problem dude it's a sauna in there
yeah it's crazy dick's out [ __ ] hot
as balls now but it is hot as balls i'm
on the train sitting down you know in
one of those two-seaters right yeah
she's dude she sits down there's other
seats she sits down right next to me
she's overweight
okay
and uh
that's right she's fat okay
and then uh i said it and she sits down
next to me
sleeveless shirt too so she their skin
contact yeah smooshes me in a thing and
i'm like there were other options yeah
i'm annoyed by this so now i'm
uncomfortable so i have to get up now
now i don't get to sit i got a lot to
say about this sure well first of all
the overweight thing like nobody has any
problem with overweight poo i was a fat
kid yeah but i don't like
yeah i was black from 8 to 12.
i was indian in high school and i was a
woman in college so all these jokes are
fine here's the problem with that
it's not no one cares about fat people
are worried about fab or hate fabulous
it's the second hand fat like i don't
care if you smoke cigarettes but when
you're smoking cigarettes in my face now
i'm smoking so your fat is affecting my
life
second hand i tried to make this
different people okay but you see what
i'm saying like your fat is now my
problem i'll get fat also like
and this is a pep you get like i i don't
think you should feel shamed for being
fat but you also you don't need to feel
pride no of course not it was an
aggressive move i'm smooshed like this
now and i'm like i can't and i'm very
much in like say the line is here i'm
like here there's space to yeah to give
i'm i'm purposely you're a thin guy
oh you know i'm spindly you should be
like second hand fat kills can you take
your fat outside man
20 feet away from the entrance actually
i should have yelled out rape
[Laughter]
well yeah uh that was a peeve that's a
woman she's you know what she's doing
she's fat spreading oh man have the meds
i love it
yeah
everyone talks about men which by the
way i've never seen in my [ __ ] life i
think that's a made-up stereotype like
that's what i do i've seen it i've seen
it he's kind of doing it right now yeah
i've seen it but anyway last week um
you would hate me one time i went to a
movie theater and i wasn't thinking and
there was only one person in the movie
theater and i i wasn't thinking and i
just sat down next day
there was no one else in this thing
that's where we're headed that's a great
galvanic joke he's like i like to go on
an empty theater sit next to the one guy
and go shh i'm trying to watch keanu
he goes the guy goes what are you doing
he goes i'm trying to watch piano
yeah that was the tag that's great um he
had some great stuff but yeah elephanta
is great yeah yeah i'm fat you know yeah
the the i guess that's another pet peeve
too it's like
some things people have like shh like i
i think it's great that people don't
feel shame for [ __ ] i don't think you
should feel shame i feel shame for being
overweight but that's my issue you're
allowed you know but i think some people
but i think my shame is bad i think some
people like have gone too far and feel
pride about [ __ ] i agree like i saw
someone talk about how they thought
their only fans account was just as um
important creatively as their stand-up
and it's like
well then you're not working that hard
on stand-up like yeah it's just like
it's one thing look i don't think you
should feel ashamed for doing only fifth
i think anyway if you want to make money
make money don't know but don't act like
a nigerian is getting a meal every time
you come on camera like don't act like
you're doing well you don't know where
that money's going yeah that's true
but i'll just say philanthropy only fans
do it that's true that would be great if
every time you jack off someone gets
oh we'd have no poverty yeah but like
i'm just saying like
you shouldn't feel ashamed for doing it
but it's still capitalism don't [ __ ]
like i just think there's too many
things that people feel proud we've gone
too far the other way yeah right and
shame there should be a minute yeah good
point just be
just be yeah it's not wrong or good and
let us tell you feel shame for being
overweight yeah and i don't think people
should i'm just saying when it affects
anything that is inconsiderate is when
i'm like all right just be considerate
yeah
right here
yes listen and by the way this is i know
some people gonna be like shut the [ __ ]
up it's the peeve section we're running
out of pieces yeah we're gonna have to
get the toast we're gonna have to switch
this to toast but it's like to your
point about the pride thing she has you
buy the balls now because you could go
hey jesus lady and she go what are you
fat shaming what do you hate fat phobic
are you a bigot and you're like well
actually
i hate you you're bad when it's on my
lap
yeah
but uh you're all right there because
we've all been next to that person on a
flight where they don't respect space
yeah and when it's when you're with that
person for a few rides on the subway
when you can i can at least get up on
the subway on a flight this is your
person yeah yeah no it's yeah we do with
bo you know we go like if someone has
really bad bo now it's affecting other
people and now we have to smell your bo
and black people have really bad beats
yeah so like
they go oh i've bee oh sorry but what's
the difference between having b.o and
affecting you and having fat infecting
you that's what i was once on a flight
uh
phil hanley was on the flight with me we
were sitting across from each other on
opposite sides and i'm next to someone
who smells like just absolutely
one of the worst smelling people i've
ever seen and i'm like let me see if i
can pull off the ultimate heist i get up
and i and i sort of the woman sitting
next to phil i say i'm so sorry this is
my good friend would you mind switching
seats
total dick move on my part i'm one of
her peeves she goes of course she
switches as she goes over she gives me a
look like
oh i saw the moment the smell hit her
and she was like oh like why i was like
because you can't go back there's
nothing you can do you can't go back
you can't be like he smells bad i'll be
honest too bad
people are just like wait a minute no no
i didn't realize that he just smells
like [ __ ] i want to switch you tricked
me
you didn't mention that in the offer
that this guy smells like [ __ ] stale
[ __ ]
he's just sitting there
that's a bit that's a great story
um
yeah yeah i'm just an [ __ ] in that
bit well
the guy the smelly guy's the [ __ ] too
there's no there's no morals on that
plane
it's all out for yourself the rules go
out the window on the plane what yeah i
try to write something you got to be
decent yeah yeah of course two years
but once you move
all bets are off yeah you you won that
battle what are some other pepe that i
had oh anyone who uh the people who
yeah cause i was thinking what you told
me pet peeves i hate when people tweet
out and i don't even disagree with this
line but i hate when they tweet it out
when people are like if you think the
pandemic is over
guess again
like even though you're saying i'm i'm
in the middle i think that's true but i
also think those people should be
executed
because i'm a centrist because it's like
you know what you're doing you're just
trying to create hysteria
because you've made that part of your
identity and it's [ __ ] such i hate i
hate the hysteria i hate it tweets like
anyone who's like guess again he's like
why are you trying what are you a pro
wrestler yeah and that's like you're
excited by it yes if a [ __ ] meteor
was coming and we had no choice you'd
still have people tweeting every [ __ ]
day that's so true
this meteor is big news quit ignoring it
we're just trying to enjoy life for the
last 20 days and every tweet's like you
can't ignore this meteor it's coming
it's bigger than we think it's like shut
up let us just enjoy whatever left we
have of life yes before these [ __ ]
monkey box even if it's [ __ ]
serious
like and i'm not saying don't take
monkey puck seriously but some people
are like this is gonna be so much worse
than and it's like shut down yeah
they're saying hit the panic button on
this [ __ ] yeah i mean it doesn't help
though it doesn't help it doesn't help
they get to look better than you too
that's also part of it also it's like no
one's trying to get monkey box yes no
one's like yeah i'll roll the dice no if
you see open sores on someone
go end the day yeah don't [ __ ] them well
the cdc says don't have multiple
partners that's going to work yeah
that's
that's how we're all trying to live our
lives or you guys maybe i know it's just
like uh it is it does feel like god does
not want us to get together it's just
like monkey pops i've got one give us a
tweet peace
i hate it when people say i don't know
who needs to hear this butt oh
that's true yeah that is annoying yeah
what was he expecting before that before
that deer
you know you'd say dear jeff but now
it's like i don't know who needs to hear
that it's just a way of saying like no
one asked for this but i'm still saying
it before we talk attention
tension blank
or this anyone who goes this and then
shares a tweet i feel like we got to do
like we did new royals i feel like i got
to do we got to do the george carlin
those people should be anyone who tweets
this should be put in a port-a-potty and
thrown into a river and that river
should be nuked or whatever yeah exactly
here's another group of people i hope
find an inoperable tumor at the base of
their spine
and then it's somebody just uses a
grammar
just guys named todd for some reason
like jesus george carly was like equally
angry about like the war and like people
who didn't have right syntax
he hated he hated uh what we did in iraq
and he hated driveways being called
driveways yeah and guys and visors yes
you're rage really
it's consistent which is funny by the
way because george carlin i know he's
best he didn't have a ponytail that
seems like something that should be on
his list a bald ponytail that should be
on his [ __ ] list for people who
should be hit over the head with a
mallet
he was that good
such a great joke i've called him before
in this pod he is underrated joke writer
he had a joke where he goes guys who are
bald with a ponytail it looks like all
their hair got together and hung
that's a itself joke that is so good
yeah
here's another group of people whose mom
i wish had a health care plan that
included abortion
he just that's a mouthful and he had
like nine of them
yeah it's not a great i saw him at when
i was at college he was super old and i
saw him at the theater there and it was
funny because he had it all written down
on notes on that so it's weird to see
him look at the notes for something like
murderous rage just like
here's another piece for some people who
should be
raped by a giant monkey it's just like
looking at the words what's special is
that this i'm working out i can't
remember i don't remember a single thing
from it it was i mean this was like i
was like 19. did he kill
yeah i remember
thinking it was a little i think it was
by the time we were like you know
he got a little angrier
oh yeah the last one was really good i
liked that for you i thought that was a
good one but the one before it was a
little i struggle with him because i
obviously think he's brilliant but he
doesn't really make me laugh like other
you know he's peppered in like he's got
stuff where you're like that's [ __ ]
hilarious and then it's ten minutes i
know and then people share it'll be like
this is brilliant i'll watch he's just
like rhyming yeah
it's like reading
and he's just like doing word like i
think you know but someone like bill
hicks always made me laugh sure because
he's just a funnier character and he was
jokier i saw carl in about 05 at the
biloxi casino i drove there from new
orleans and uh it was bad it was really
bad because first it's a casino second
it's mississippi yeah and third he was
getting heckled the entire time
everybody was hammered and he was going
i'm uptown but i'm downloaded
but i'm front and center and they were
just like
oh
what the [ __ ] say this he was trying to
work out one of his limber key bits and
they weren't having it and they were
like do the seven dirty words your [ __ ]
what it kind of became dr seuss at the
end a little darkness up there
[Laughter]
i don't know i think it's also he was i
think he was so groundbreaking when
someone's so groundbreaking sometimes
you watch again you're like i don't
there's no jokes it's just like a
statement it was it was cute and clever
and fun
tonight so many good specials of course
i'm a huge i can do his whole album his
whole catalog i think you know what it
was sometimes and there are bits of it i
think really i think it was so right all
the time that sometimes i think to be
really funny you have to be a little
wrong you know what i mean i think it
was kind of awesome
uh provocative stuff though that's true
when you think about like how we got
excited by
multiple people dying i mean
like jesus i know i know i mean he
called feminist come catchers he called
eddie murphy the n word like he went he
went for it that's pretty amazing
of course they don't care i love that
joke i said that to you and you're like
i don't know about that one i was like i
was at my house like this is gold it's
hilarious but it's like one of those
jokes you're like that's not flying
today yeah well that was the best part
of the [ __ ] yeah yeah but i mean like uh
obviously the abortion joke is one of
the best ever
i mean it's uh i mean his bit about like
the planet's gonna be fine we're the
ones dying is like one of the most like
that's delightful 11 minutes yeah that's
one of the most insightful things ever
yeah yeah plastic bags yeah that's a
great because that is true we're always
like like the world's endings like
no we're ending yeah we're going yeah
the world's not going anywhere mountains
are gonna be fought he's about to the
mountains ain't worried about climbing
he's also one of those brilliant guys
where liberals and conservatives on
twitter are misinterpreted
and they claim him he's like the bible
now or you're like
well they're just like this is what he
meant i'm like i don't know if that's
what he was saying liberals are that
neo-nazis are sharing that edward bit
we've just talked to him exactly exactly
and liberals are sharing he said it what
can i say yeah
yeah no he does he does work for uh for
everyone um what are the other pet
peeves oh well i do a bit about this but
i do think hot people using body
positivity is something that i really
like hate like
hot people
posting pictures where they're really
hot on instagram but then acting like
they're brave about it like is that
happening i feel like that happens oh
wow i see that yeah really just like
just being like like i'm no longer
ashamed of this mole on my knees oh
perfect shut up i'm trying to masturbate
feel more shame you can't get up with
his pride
i feel shame
behind that mold your knee get on your
knees the problem with pride it really
keeps you from coming ah
not me i jerk off to the gay flag
can someone send us a joan rivers and a
george carlin yeah on a wall of death
here oh how do we not have a carlin i
can bring in an apple oh [ __ ] i've been
saying they should do this at clubs for
years you know how comic clubs have the
pictures on the wall i think they should
always put the picture the people died
on their own yeah yeah
yeah pretty much yeah norman's he's
going soon yeah i got it
norm looks so weird in that picture
that's a great photo there's like a
light from like a light shining on him
in a weird way he was a underrated
handsome guy oh young norm is very
handsome good looking matinee good looks
i like how you only put the dead comics
you like
[Laughter]
like i'm thinking about all the dead
comics i like pinette i like louis
anderson
we gotta get more but where do we send
where do we come to send stuff man
251 39 west 39th street you got to get
gilbert you can't have oh
gilbert
yeah that was a great dock people send
these in man we're not oh they send them
in
i picked up one of the prior ones but
rapping rodney baby we got we had paulie
walnuts before we died this one might be
bad luck oh yeah one of the great
moments in sopranos you you love
sopranos like we do i do too
i was so i was listening to like someone
was doing an impression of a scene the
other day on video
they were doing a good impression
they're doing impressions polly walnuts
and james ganofini but the lines
themselves they were doing was from the
movie and it or the show just made me
realize like how [ __ ] funny that show
is and yet they play it for straight the
whole time yeah and yet the lines on the
page are like [ __ ] hilarious so fun
it was like a scene where they're like
have to re-dig up an old body and they
just start reminiscing about that like
the good old days
and it's so funny but that whole show is
just
like comedy played completely straight
yes you know what i mean we always talk
about the uh the intervention for
chrissy
i'm on the floor one of the
funniest scenes of all time like i also
think about i think we've talked about
it but uh the the episode where michael
imperioli takes the acting class
i know i know it's a great show but i
mean you know yeah there's so much
there's so much there yeah but that
intervention scene when paulie's like
incredible he's trying to be
constructive [ __ ] that yeah let him take
his medicine ah you're weak
he calls his mom a [ __ ] but he's so
detailed that scene and that's to say
like it could have been broad in a bad
way like analyze this and it's not and
it's created its own tone where it's
like on one hand it's a mobster telling
someone they're weak during an
intervention which is seems like a
sketch sure i mean right that's so real
to the point where one of the most real
moments in that scene
is when gandalfine finds out he killed
the dog yeah he's like you killed little
cozette the fact that you know tony
soprano would know the name
he's a sociopath and he just loves
animals exactly he's always and
sociopathy loves animals so he just
always knows somebody's like
you [ __ ] kill little coza like
he can't let it go he keeps bringing it
back
yeah comedy i mean the the thing about
that show that i i think the detail in
the dialogue the history of people's
lives and the dialogue is like unmatched
i mean i remember
there's one scene where she has a crazy
roommate in college yeah
and
one the girl just at one point just says
this i feel like they should teach us
the class she just says i really miss my
ferret oh and
it's just perfect that's so like you're
just like yeah she would have a pet fair
but you're like any other screenwriter
would put like cat or dog but they're
like this minor character and he has a
pet ferret
fair because she's a weird person you
know it's just perfect like the show is
just full of and the kids are just so
well written i mean i know there's a
scene i love the scene where
jamie lynn zigler you know they're
trying to punish her and she's like
whatever when she runs and carmela has
some line along the lines of like what
are we going to do when they realize
we're powerless yeah like there's
nothing we can really do like holy [ __ ]
they nailed the home life
that humanized him yeah i also think
it's the only show i mean some people
probably i think it's the only show
where both the husband and wife are
equally interesting
i think most shows one of the one of the
characters is usually way more
interesting you know i like breaking bad
but that wife's a dullard you know what
i mean there's usually there's usually
one character even in the best shows but
that's the one show yeah she's kind of a
wet blanket yeah yeah just let the guy
sell some mess
have you seen young sheldon
[Laughter]
but uh you pointed out something to me
that blew my mind about how it's the
only show with that much character
development like ralphie you know what
movie every character likes yeah which
i've never thought of gladiator that's a
gladiator which is so him that's one of
the great detail of the show you
literally know what everyone likes and
you know they all [ __ ] yeah you know
that richie likes to [ __ ] with a gun to
it
you know that ralphie likes it in the
ass yes but knowing what people like the
only other thing that's similar to that
is big lebowski where you know what
everyone is interested in right right
but like in sopranos like you know
gandolfini loves the history channel
yeah stuff you know he loves coming hey
fields cagney yeah you know the
godfather you know he likes godfather
too more than godfather one yeah they go
back to italy you know you know carmella
like certain books you know whatever the
movie she was watching uh totally
remains of the day or whatever at one
point you know what they all are you
know the kids at the south park it's
just like seeing what someone likes it's
just very rare movies because most maybe
the characters aren't
really seen that detailed in a real way
it really makes you feel like i love it
connection yeah no it's the best show
it's the best show where actually the
first season i think is still the best
season wow yeah you think and i still
think it's the best show yeah what'd you
think of the scene of the pines with the
russian guy the green beret
it's interesting all right i love that
that episode but a lot of people are
like i didn't like that you know there
was a scene they deleted where they go
to the i guess it reveals what the uh
what actually happened there's a scene
where uh
they go to the the guy the the head of
the other the russians
and the guy who they shot is there he
like made his way back but he's kind of
brain dead oh interesting like he can
barely talk yeah and he's like in like a
little plastic like yeah
and so so from the perspective of the
screenplay that guy did survive
and if you watch it actually like you
can see it's not like i don't think it's
definitely a kill shot yeah but yeah
they definitely intended for him to be
uh it's probably better to leave it open
though didn't imperially write or direct
that one i think he said actually
yeah purely only directed to some other
ones i think but we shall be directing
that one yeah yeah listen to some of
their podcasts and perioli's great yeah
oh yeah it's like that now what's his
name
he worked uh a club that steve sheriff
managed in the 80s i heard it was scary
yeah it was a casino and dana by the end
told me he was like sick of the gig so
he just went on stage with his underwear
over his jeans and didn't address it and
just did his act
just as like a [ __ ] you to the club and
i guess after he got off stage uh steve
shripper walks up to him he goes you
disrespected me you disrespected the
club it's like he is that guy
i think from what i've read about him
he's actually much scarier because
that's like the nicest guy in
right in sopranos even though he does
kill somebody he murders me but he feels
bad yeah yeah but like he's nice to
junior yeah
he's definitely the nicest guy on that
show this is bakula yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah bad rules i think he's like much
scariest but uh that's kind of funny
that he did that i once on a show the
early days where
which is just the worst early days
you're just having cancerable moments
yeah every second yes i had i thought
it'd be really funny to go on stage with
one my zipper down and one ball hanging
out
i thought it'd be so funny just idea i
in my head i was like it's hilarious
idea that someone doesn't know a ball is
hanging out of their zipper yeah but
what i didn't realize it's funny it took
me this to realize why this joke
wouldn't work is that there's no moment
where i'm like see right because the
people have to just look and be like
is
his ball out yeah and so it's just like
a weird no turn yeah there's no turn and
there's no moment where they realize
that i'm
in on it yeah yeah you know i mean so
there's no moment on like gotcha so i'm
just doing jokes and they're just like
you're just doing dead baby jokes
[Laughter]
they're just like yeah and they're just
watching like like is that a ball
that's why that guy got strangled it is
a ball it's not a ball
i would take my balls yeah but so anyway
so that's what i i
sometimes you just gotta take your ball
out on stage to realize that it's not
gonna work but you need you need to
learn you need to workshop yeah you got
a workshop and i have a photo of ari at
denver comedy works with he's got huge
balls and they he pulled him out no
shaft and he's doing a set and i have a
photo of it in case he ever [ __ ] me
over
joe used to make fun of me because i've
been complimenting on my balls being big
and he's like he tried to do a bit of he
has a lot of bits about me big he does
have a few bits about it yeah he's like
i wrote a bit about you and then it's
off stage like i got a friend who's so
ugly yeah
i've heard that
but he said that uh if someone
compliments you on having big balls
it means you have a small dick but i
don't think so no you got a big boy two
things can be true i don't think my dick
is that small but i do have big balls
separation of balls and dicks right
they're not it's all it's not like yeah
it's not like it's not like you have one
dick right next to another dick it's
different things yes you know yeah very
different but maybe have a small dick i
don't know
what an ending to this episode yes
really uh call in if you think it's
smart
we should get a phone in here that could
ring and it's just your mom it just
doesn't work
we should get one of those duck phones
remember those like quack quack
hey look how cute
oh yeah yeah jimmy i'm talking about oh
yeah no he's uh yeah that actually is a
mannequin he wasn't in the room
um oh yeah those are my dates from like
last year
i put the good ones up i see um
my mom texted me the other day i i
posted it but she said uh this was the
best of your shows i still don't like
the leg joke
but other than that she's trying to
write peg
that's adorable that's too special no no
she just saw me the other day and i
thought oh wow but it's funny like i
didn't do the getting peg joke in front
of your mom oh yeah
yes
that's impressive i uh but yeah it is it
is i never thought i'd get to a point in
my life where my i now know my mom tried
to type peg
and it auto-corrected and she said it to
me it's just like an interesting
probably for the best it autocorrected
yeah you don't want your mom sending
those texts out it is crazy i do talk
about getting [ __ ] in the ass with a
strap-on yeah i don't know
yeah and she doesn't like dirty language
well yeah what were you thinking was
that like a [ __ ] you mom
no i just don't when my parents come i
just do my act and like
leave the cards on the table yeah i just
i don't like changing [ __ ] for people
coming no i don't yeah i don't either
but uh i mean there is a bit i talk
about like my mom's supposed to see i
didn't do that one ah okay
i guess it'd be weird if you was like i
love the peg joke
why didn't you the one about my [ __ ]
yeah
you've gotten soft do you change your
material for your parents oh yeah oh
really i don't but i only had one it's
funny i did one when i did the beacon my
parents came
i did one joke about my mom that i don't
think
she enjoys
uh and i asked my therapist who was
sitting behind her any reaction to her
and it goes i don't think she liked that
one oh wait your therapist was sitting
behind her yeah that's hilarious yeah
that's like some symbolism or something
but uh
yeah he just wrote
the funny thing is the joke didn't even
make this special so i'm like you
probably didn't have to do that well
there's your therapist the next session
was like by the way your mom wouldn't
stop [ __ ] talking to her
i had to strengthen you tried to kick
her out yeah we got to wrap this because
mark's got a gig
should we do a quick bit or just plug
gage what do you think well i mean if we
do a one line of reach we can make it
but maybe you just do a bit cause you do
a bit do a bit um i've been doing this
dude
something new right yeah undone uh
undone i've been working on this joke
about um
how i'm like uh
walking with this girl this true story i
walk with this girl in new york and
there's like a homeless guy jacking off
in a cardboard box and she's like i've
never felt so violated
and i was like you feel violated we just
walked through his room unannounced
hello
i like that you know imagine if you're
masturbating and like a couple just
barges in like uh yeah
gross disgusting
i've never felt so violated that's a
good point but the part i try to work on
then i go and this is i guess where it
doesn't work i go uh
granted if someone barges in my room
while i was masturbating i'd probably
stop masturbating ah i wouldn't just
watch them while they're walking
thinking it's directed at her it could
be directed to you that's true yeah
exactly it probably was yeah yeah
interesting
but uh yeah so that's something i'm
gonna do that's that's
it's kind of a genius diabolical move on
the hobos part because he has the upper
hand because i could say a genius bit
i'm so excited oh sorry i like the bit
but it's a great bit but it's uh it's
funny that he's like hey well this is
where i live you're coming in well
that's well that's the part i've been
trying to explore it doesn't work but i
guess i've been trying to say like it's
not and this is the thing i can't
formulate
very well but like people get grossed
out about people masturbating and
they're like it's disgusting they're
doing it in public and it's like but
that's all they have right there is no
private and it's actually not wrong that
they're masturbating because everyone
masturbates right it's wrong that they
don't have walls around them yeah tell
them for woke people like you have wall
privilege yeah exactly it is wall
privilege it is if you're free if you
think it's [ __ ] up build up a house
because build that wall because you're
like new rules yeah if you rule because
it's this
it's hypocritical to get a uh grossed
out by someone masturbating when you
also masturbate every day you just have
a house right well i i don't know i
don't know that's gonna hold up in court
said this on stage i was like i don't
think this is i was like it's not funny
but it's a good point maybe but i was
like i don't think it's a good point
either maybe you compare it to [ __ ]
or another thing that's like also we all
do that's private right you know yeah
like where do you [ __ ] because he's
mcdonald's bathroom that's where you
should be jacking off
yeah because if it was it's something
the sexual component changes it because
if he was [ __ ] you go oh this poor
guy doesn't have any walls he's got a
[ __ ] in public but if he's jerking off
you're like what a creep and you're like
it's the same thing same thing you're
sexual yeah you're just sexual and you
do it you do both both are needs yeah
and also it's like the only good thing
about being homeless is you can't get
cancelled
like it's the one thing you care about
you can't regret it you're not gonna
take away your
something to take the box yeah you're
not going to take away your time i can
put you in jail i guess that's a home
it's your backfires all right all right
so like that's a home
compare the house
into a prison cell home sweetheart
all right a home but it's a house it's a
hostile you can't get canceled because
your life is [ __ ] what that's what is
yeah exactly you can't bring someone
down right so of course you're gonna
jack off in public if if you couldn't
get cancelled
you'd also jack off and punch ah yeah
good point and maybe you could do a
silly turn at the end to make it a
little a little levity like take out my
dick and jack off well take one ball out
no
uh like you go maybe it's a good way to
get like stop uh rent hiking you know
the landlord comes in and you're like
and he's like never mind i keep the
wreck
yeah you're right yeah just to you know
tie it up i'll try i'll take all those
notes
take a note uh make sure to watch run on
special uh on
from
youtube
now
i uh taped out the comedy seller in
april sal accused directed it brilliant
job
and uh i heard your mom gave it an
a-minus yeah one joke not enough peck
jokes and uh oh wait you talking about
sound cues
but yeah it's uh
yeah it's on youtube i you know i'm
putting it out myself and all that [ __ ]
and it's good for you spent all my
savings on it so uh go check it out it's
on my you go to my youtube channel i
guess ron on hershberg
r-a-a-n-a-n-h-e-r-s-h-b-e
used to be ron on hitler he changed it
so check it out it's a kill i saw it
live as well and it was one of those
like i never get to see you do an hour
because we're all busy doing our own
[ __ ] and so to see you do a full hour is
like this is killer oh so check it out
you both check it out and uh
bodegacatspirits.com yes please get
bodega cat the whiskey is out you can
get merch we might be drunkpod.com the
patreon uh we might be drunkpod at
gmail.com or i got a netflix special out
please watch that same time tomorrow
mark we're gonna be on the road i'm all
over the road i'm uh you know jesus
christ uh
richmond uh
seattle portland vancouver toronto new
orleans new haven and
boston check out marknomancomedy.com san
jose as well i got louisville irvine uh
omaha
phoenix uh
jesus christ new brunswick okc
uh springfield missouri fort wayne
indiana all over the to spokane tacoma
kansas city all over samrell.com shows
watch the special please appreciate you
guys oh and uh
yeah i'll be at comedy comedy on stage
september 27th one of the best clubs in
the country one of the best and follow
me on instagram run on comedy you got
new stuff
uh yeah yeah
there you go folks
professional all right we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
[Music]
we
might me
[Music]